i am inevitable i am iron man
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we are team theorists speaking of
if you want to meld into our symbiote
that's now absorbed over 10 million
subscribers hit that red button down
below we'd be glad to have you merge
into the theorist family hey you press
the button how you feel about that one
venom outstanding now let's fight all
the heads off follow them up at the
corner no we will not bite off their
heads okay maybe just one you know it
absolutely takes a village to make the
kind of quality content that you've come
to expect at the rate that you crave it
and that's why i can really appreciate
solid teamwork you know who else can
appreciate solid teamwork eddie brock
and is way too close for comfort buddy
venom how's that for a seamless segue
ladies and gentlemen if you think your
roommates have been a little too close
for comfort over the last year lockdown
just imagine how much worse it would be
if they actually lived inside of you and
then you know just randomly decided to
consume whole human heads in one bite on
that note can i just digress for a
second here where are those heads going
are they going into eddie's stomach like
how is he digesting a full human skull
it's not like venom has a physical
structure that contains or digests these
sorts of things he's using eddie's body
as a host so i don't know probably a
theory better suited for another day
also since i'm on this whole digression
might as well include this too did you
know that he's eating the brains so that
way he doesn't go insane yeah it's
another weird detail from the comics if
the symbiotes don't eat human brains on
a regular basis they go insane either
that or they gotta eat chocolates kind
of gives new meaning to those snickers
commercials you're not you when you're
hungry anyway after being bounced around
the release calendar more times than
black widow bouncing off of hvac systems
it's finally time for venom 2 to be
released into theaters with the big bad
being none other than well venom himself
he's not really a big hero here let's be
honest dude kind of sucks but the even
worse villain this time around is serial
killer cletus cassidy and his personal
symbiote carnage it's not symbiote right
i know they say that in the movie let me
just double check symbiote yeah symbiote
i don't know who says symbiote so in
true film theory fashion i wanted to
take a look at who should win this
battle not who will win because we all
know the reality of franchise-based
storytelling dictates that our title
character will have to continue in some
form but rather who should win like if
there really were two real-life
symbiotes modeled after venom and
carnage and we stuck them in a fight
against each other who would come out on
top and this question is pretty darn
interesting since at first glance the
two symbiotes seem to be pretty much
pallet swapped versions of each other
but when you look closer there's
actually a lot of differences in the way
that they function the ways that they
interact with their hosts and the way
that they view the world which would
give an advantage to one over the other
in a 1v1 brawl so today we're looking at
the comics the movies and the real
worlds of science and psychology to
determine in a real world battle of
carnage vs venom who would reign supreme
for those of you who skipped the venom
movie because it wasn't officially in
the mcu yet or weren't fans of comic
books from the super edgy totally rad
90s era let's quickly go over the
relevant factoids for our venom carnage
battle today venom is truly two
different entities sharing a body first
we have the journalist eddie brock he's
a human nothing extraordinary to say
about him secondly though we have
ourselves an alien symbiote that infects
eddie bonding with his nervous system
this symbiote is what allows brock to
transform into the black behemoth known
as venom on the other side we have
carnage though we haven't seen too much
of carnage in the movies yet the story
in the comics goes that while breaking
eddie brock out of prison the venom
symbiote creates an asexually produced
offspring that ends up finding the
serial killer cletus cassidy as its host
in the movie it looks like cletus might
actually bite eddie and get a piece of
the symbiote that way i have tasted
blood before and that
is not it the interesting piece here
though is that rather than bonding with
cassidy's nervous system this new
symbiote instead bonds with cletus's
blood thus creating the red-looking
monster called carnage and you see this
subtle difference actually gives us our
first major basis for comparison a
neural connection in venom versus a
sanguineous connection or blood
connection with carnage while on paper
that might seem like an arbitrary
distinction it actually ties directly
into both of these symbiotes potential
strengths and weaknesses venom being
linked directly to brock's nervous
system gives him a solid scientific
reason to have stronger faster
perception and reflexes much akin to
peter parker's spider sense venom's
connections with the nervous system
would also give him advanced control
over the body and therefore better
precision in his movements remember in a
fight strength isn't everything accuracy
and control are gonna matter a lot so
venom is actually working with a major
advantage here as well however venom's
direct ties into the human nervous
system are a massive double-edged sword
because it also comes with a huge set of
disadvantages as we've seen in both the
comics and movies venom is very weak to
sound and sonic based attacks sure this
originated as just a weakness concocted
for a fictional character but a real
life symbiote like this would
scientifically have a weakness to
intense perceptual inputs a boosted
nervous system like the one that venom
gives to brock would in fact result in
sound being amplified and any weaknesses
that symbiotes naturally had to sonic
activity would likely be boosted as well
carnage uses screech it is super
effective this also opens up venom to
all kinds of nervous system based
weaknesses rapid changes in temperature
bright flashing lights overwhelmingly
bad smells these are all things that are
unpleasant to normal humans and could
ultimately the heightened
awareness of venom let me be clear while
these things might not be all that
effective in the comics out in the real
world battle against the symbiote
connected to your nerves it's suddenly
gonna matter a lot carnage on the other
hand is gonna get away with a lot more
here because he's connected to the blood
his weaknesses are much fewer and far
between blood isn't going to be weak to
things like sound or flashing lights
because blood has nothing to do with
human perception it's no weaker to sound
than any other molecule in the body and
well that's just me running an analysis
on what the real world science would
look like this actually holds true in
the comics surprisingly enough all the
symbiotes start as weak to sonics to
some extent not that sort of sonic
carnage eventually loses that
vulnerability now admittedly it has less
to do with his blood connection and more
to do with him being granted extra
abilities through the powers of ancient
magic
whatever it is i'm just here to say that
the science actually supports his powers
as seen in the comics so if a blood
connection protects carnage from most of
the things that would harm venom then
what is he gonna be vulnerable to maybe
heat that's traditionally one of the
other classic symbiote weaknesses in the
comics and yeah you can definitely heat
the blood up enough for it to boil and
degrade but neurons are gonna be just as
susceptible to those high temperatures
so venom would be equally at risk and
again in the comics we see in the web of
venom that dark carnage is no longer
susceptible to fire how about
electricity this is still carnage's main
weakness in the comics and yeah
electricity would absolutely hurt red
blood cells but again it would also
affect venom considering that the
neurons of eddie's body literally run on
electrical pulses one of the only things
that carnage seems weak to that venom
wouldn't be is probably the least
exciting thing possible blood-based
illnesses blood can be weak to itself as
is the case with proliferative blood
disorders like leukemia or autoimmune
neutropenia where blood cells attack
other blood cells but for as much as
blasting carnage with radiation until he
has cancer sounds like the sort of
solution we'd come up with for a film
theory on how to kill carnage i'm gonna
venture a wild guess that it's not gonna
be all that helpful in a battle against
venom i mean if the movie does go in
that direction maybe we'll just pretend
that this was a prediction theory all
along but i'm not gonna be holding my
breath on that one more likely this
movie's gonna come down to a cgi
slugfest in the dark with some kind of
sky beam in the background so carnage
being blood-based rather than neuron
based has fewer weaknesses so then how
are his strengths well he might not be
as fast or reactive as venom but he will
be stronger increased blood flow is
associated with muscle growth because
red blood cells deliver oxygen to
working tissues more oxygen means more
work that translates to stronger muscles
and also more stamina it also means that
unlike venom carnage in real life should
have the ability to regenerate you see
with human neurons what you see is kind
of what you get if something gets
damaged in the nervous system it's
pretty much gone for good unless it gets
actively repaired or replaced their
lifespan is your lifespan blood cells
though those things are a dime a dozen
nearly two million red blood cells in
the adult human body die every second in
fact your body makes 3.8 million cells
every second and most of them are red
blood cells so an organism that attaches
to the blood is going to be much more
difficult to completely wipe out because
he's constantly multiplying and
regenerating himself and ironically
enough all of this actually matches with
carnage's comic lore again it is weird
the coincidence here the comics come up
with all these wacky reasons to explain
the symbiote's powers they're aliens
they've been affected with magic they've
been attached to spider-man's
radioactive body at some point whatever
but in truth all of it actually ties
back to the real world science in one
way or another we see in the comics that
carnage unlike venom does have
regenerative powers he does tend to be
depicted as stronger he does have
incredible stamina heck even his comic
ability to create weapons from his own
body and launch them makes more sense
for a character that's associated with
blood we've got a lot of extra blood
cells to spare why not grab a few of
them form them into an axe and launch
them at your nearest web slinger venom
wouldn't be able to do stuff like that
because the cells he's working with are
limited in number and highly fragile so
looking at just the bonding behavior
this one is a clear victory for carnage
no question from a physical standpoint
the blood bond has many more advantages
and fewer weaknesses but there's still
one other angle that i want to pursue
here and that's the psychological
component and it all boils down to one
line
we are venom the symbiote and eddie are
working together as two separate
entities within one body cletus cassidy
on the other hand always refers to
himself as a singular entity i am
carnage who then wins the psychological
battle one singular entity or two
sharing the same body researchers in the
psychology world use a lot of different
models to predict human behavior and one
of the most popular currently is called
the big five or ocean model an acronym
for its five metrics openness
conscientiousness extroversion
agreeableness and neuroticism with
advent of social media these metrics
have exploded into popular use as data
engineers design automated tests to
extract ocean metrics from your social
media data and predict your online
activities that is no joke that is a
real thing these metrics actually serve
as the basis for many of those
terrifying algorithms that seem to know
exactly what you're thinking and how to
advertise directly to you so yeah
there's an actual reason i'm bringing
this up anyway as you might expect
certain metrics correlate with certain
kinds of success and also show your
ability to work together i want to focus
specifically on the conscientiousness
metric which is often associated with
success in different kinds of workplaces
on one end of the conscientiousness
scale are the efficient and organized
people while on the other side sit the
extravagant or careless people and mind
you these aren't my terms they are the
official terms used in this model and
they're designed to be non-judgmental
though i would argue that the word
careless really feels judgy to me anyway
in jobs that don't require a high level
of technical knowledge conscientiousness
highly correlates with success people
who are organized efficient and
goal-oriented have a much higher
probability of success in these jobs
than the extravagant or careless people
who tend to get bored or frustrated
overwhelmed or distracted before the
job's done cletus cassidy is extravagant
to say the least he's a violent serial
killer and not like the dexter type who
meticulously plans out his crime one of
the reasons the police didn't catch
cassidy until he had committed at least
11 murders or 23 by his own count was
because his crimes were patternless
cassidy doesn't kill for a political
reason or some deep repressed traumatic
reason he killed because he wanted to he
didn't see the point in life totally
random carnage his symbiote is also
extravagant actually it's probably
better to say that he doesn't come
packaged with a solid identity as we
hear in the spider-man cartoon i get to
be like brock similar but different once
you bond it will reflect your hatred for
humanity your lust for destruction
contrast cletus with eddie who is much
more organized though he's definitely
more in the middle of the
conscientiousness spectrum we see that
eddie is more than capable of organizing
investigations into powerful people he's
goal driven he stops at literally
nothing to get his questions to carlton
drake at the beginning of the first film
resulting in his loss of a highly
skilled job eddie has much more
perseverance when presented with a
challenge and that challenge isn't just
carnage it's also venom who is
definitely more on the careless and
extravagant end of the conscientiousness
spectrum 2018's venom was all about
eddie brock and his symbiote learning to
deal with each other eddie feels out of
control at first and fights against the
symbiote's influence it's only when
eddie voluntarily lets the symbiote back
into his body towards the end of the
movie that venom truly achieves his full
power the extremely powerful but chaotic
venom succeeds in part thanks to eddie
brock's psychological profile reigning
him in being more strategic and focusing
venom's incredible power so while
they're certainly operating a separate
individual sharing one body their
strengths and weaknesses ultimately
balance each other out as opposed to the
chaotic extravagant cletus being made
more extreme by the equally chaotic
symbiote what's more eddie also gets the
advantage of two brains because you know
what they say two heads are better than
one and as it turns out that it's
scientifically proven as the report
optimally interacting minds shows not
really going to do a deep dive into it
here because it's not really that
exciting but the tl dr is that yeah two
people communicating with each other and
working together does ultimately lead to
better results than one person working
alone so for eddie and venom who have
had some time together to work things
out communication is gonna come as
second nature so venom's real advantage
over carnage isn't physical it's
actually psychological carnage has
nearly all of eddie's strengths beat and
his weaknesses are much less likely to
come into play than eddies are but eddie
has the personality for the job and the
ability to work with his teammate to
achieve something greater than carnage
can achieve on his own in the most
ironic twist of all a battle between two
super powerful blobs of alien goo is
ultimately decided by the puny humans
that are wearing the suits but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut
you